[音楽]
みなさんこんにちはー
突然ですがみなさんの変人と言われてどう思いますか
変人っていうのは褒め言葉なんでしょうか木梨方も何でしょうか
捉え方は人それぞれだと思いますが私は変人であることは必ず自分のティア3になる
記すペリー透けるような経験が私にそう教えてくれました
尻3スケールはロンドーから3時間半も本当にちょっと中心地を離れたら
機に芸能羊ばっかりがいるみたいなあの田舎のところなんですけどまずシリーズペリー
に降りたくて私が受けられたのはこの
あのー
ひさしにも言ってる本当に1800年代と買い取ったら建てられた煉瓦建築の校舎とか
全寮制の不明瞭の建物だったりとかあのー
も沿わないんですけれど本当にハリーポッターの世界に迷い込んだような気持ちでした
[音楽]
ブーブーって言ってサッカーの試合が本当に行く路線で切るくらい広瀬アリ
ブーブー本当に買ったてもう今日か
に建物を設けられているほど事実したしていく
あとは a 棟
本当に積極税あふれる仙頭が音と人参先生と生徒で
残塁事業熱い議論が炸裂する養成事業が半壊と正宇治業が毎回でとてもあの糞領土が
成り立っている素晴らしい学校でした
と私自身日本ではできないことに造成しようっていう思いで自分でやったことが甘かっ
たことに色々調整したんですけど
一つはミツバチ飼育サッカーに入ったりだとか
あのう
[音楽]
わたし自身153設置したらいいんですけど
170cm の人たちと一緒にボートを漕いだり
あなたはあの
だぞ9月道あったわけでもないのに
聖歌隊に入ってみたりと本当にいろんな活動をさせても最終年間した
長い色で本当にあっという間に過ぎてしまった1年間だったんですけどやっぱりあの
もう行かないこともあって勉強やスポーツ人間関係などをいろいろ苦労したことはあり
ましたけど勉強スポーツっていうのを自分で何とか努力すればけっにもなる問題で人間
関係
困ったのが自分の中で振り返ってみて思うことです
逃げ関係何が一番だよ何だったかんっていうと桜
差別とまでは言わないんですけど人種の区別っていうのがあって結構アジア人
イギリス人というふうに二分化している状態が知れず便利ではありました
私はその中国人ではないし
もちろんし熱いんだけど認めまあ写真けど中国人ではないし中国も話せないかといって
イギリス人でもないから
その中間の立場ってとても複雑な心境でした
競馬を今こうして考えてみてやっぱりその中間立場っていうのがだからこそその吟醸
日付けたのかなっていうのはありのフィー帰っていいと思います
g 社の素問題とか彩未ソロ3トンいいが未だに完全に解決できたといけないんです
けどと音たしいろいろな活動を通して本当に良い日あった相撲日足
生化学サークルの活動がありました
鳥のばどうチングとか護憲派池の水質検査とかをやっているって言うのを聞いて興味を
持った自然変わるスタッフ行ったんですけど
ブーバ一番いいからてぃく
here 泊しくっていう
しけどどっちロスコ
活動以外でもすごいなった訳なってあのクリスマス何して保ったかっていう頃ちょっと
した会話をしてたら夜中近くの墓墓ばね
お墓についている苔を額超過してたバカ言っている
すごいマニアックな子なんですけど
結局その本当に調査したものを実際労務を書きありで
学校で表彰される戻していて彼女からローランス自分が好きなことをとことんまで行っ
て自分を主張して何か思えるって言うの大切さを感じから学びました
まだ私か r 18年間しか愛し別に育英高アティたわけでもないけどそんな私で
モーターぬーんだなっていう
メッキ経験し殺さた
の出会いでしたロジャーもう70歳と花のお爺さんなんですけど私が写真撮るのが好き
あのう側ミイラシーターのが好きだっていうのを知って写真付きのプロさんに紹介して
もらったんですけど
8観光1年間覚えること終盤の入ったところに
ちょっと一緒に写真撮りに行かないかって言って二人であの
ん
ブーブーを写真に行かあったんですけど彼と話してその1年間同一 ip 命じた
あってあなたみたいにそれで世界でていく安全安心であったの初めてだということをお
金を渡していました
てこのはまだ18年かして生きてるし
あくまでひどいの留学生ぷして君に来ているだけの私が17歳も歳が70歳のおじい
さんにそんなことを言われる
自分対策ほどしてないって思ってたけど誰かに伝えることがあるんだなっていうのを
同会とのえらいを通して学びました
自分をダンスっていうことよりも周囲に合わせることが社会に重要視されている気がし
ますけど自分を主張することも同じくらい大切なんだなっていうふうに私は思ってい
ます
遠回りとは違うからこそ気づけることがあったり
もう一違うからこそ自分の誰かに教えられることがある
変人ラリーそれって胸を持っていればいろいろなことが見えてくるんじゃないかな
エンジンであることは必ず金なんじゃないでしょうか
以上で終わりますご静聴ありがとうございます
[拍手]